>> Tucker: WELCOME BACK TO
THE SPECIAL "INSIDE THE
ISSUES."
WE TAKE A LOOK NOW AT ONE OF
AMERICA'S MOST INSTINCTIVE AND
ENDANGERED RIGHTS, THE RIGHT
TO BEAR ARMS.
AMERICA IS UNUSUAL COUNTRY IN
A NUMBER OF WAYS.
BUT ONE WAY THAT THE COUNTRY
STANDS OUT IS THE MUCH
STRONGER FIRE ARMS CULTURE.
AMERICA HAS MORE FIREARMS THAN
PEOPLE.
PROBABLY MORE CIVILIAN OWNED
GUNS PER CAPITA THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
UNLIKE ANY OTHER COUNTRY, GUN
OWNERSHIP IS CONSTITUTIONALLY
PROTECTED HERE.
WHY IS THAT?
A NEW LOOK EXPLORES THE
AMERICA'S LONG RELATIONSHIP
WITH FIREARMS.
DAVID WROTE IT.
"FIRST FREEDOM, RIDE THROUGH
AMERICA'S ENDURING HISTORY
WITH THE GUN."
AND HE JOINS US IN STUDIO.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: WHY IS GUN
OWNERSHIP CONSTITUTIONALLY
PROTECTED IN THE UNITED
STATES?
>> TWO REASONS.
NATURAL RIGHT TO PROTECT
YOURSELF, YOUR FAMILY AND
PROPERTY.
THE MOST IMPORTANT RIGHT.
WITHOUT IT NONE OF THE OTHERS
EXIST.
>> IT'S OBVIOUSLY BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE WHO FOUGHT AT CONCORDE
AND LEXINGTON WEREN'T FIGHTING
INCOME INEQUALITY.
THEY WERE FIGHTING BECAUSE
PEOPLE WERE COMING TO TAKE
THEIR WEAPONS.
THEY COULD HAVE TAKEN THE
PROPERTY OR THE OTHER RIGHTS
IF THEY HAVE WEAPONS.
>> Tucker: SO WITHOUT A GUN,
POWERFUL PEOPLE MAKE YOU OBEY.
>> OF COURSE.
>> ONLY INDEPENDENT IF YOU
DEFEND YOURSELF.
>> AUTHORITARIAN IDEA TO
PROTECT AND TAKE MEANS FROM
THE INDIVIDUAL.
>> Tucker: BUT WE ARE TOLD
IT'S A WAY TO PROTECT THE REST
OF US FROM ONE ANOTHER, TAKING
THE GUNS AWAY.
DO YOU THINK THERE IS ANOTHER
MOTIVE AT WORK?
>> I THINK IT'S AUTHORITARIAN
MOTIVE.
HOW PEOPLE TREATS RIGHT TO
SELF-DOFFS IS HOW THEY THINK
OF THE STATE.
WE ARE BASED ON THE INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS, NOT THE COLLECTIVE
RIGHTS.
SO THAT GOES FOR GUNS.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE RESPECT
ANY OF THE RIGHTS IN THE BILL
OF RIGHTS, ACTUALLY.
>> Tucker: SO THE INSTINCT
TO TAKE PEOPLE'S GUNS AWAY IS
BIGGER, YOU ARE ARGUING THAN
THE DESIRE --
>> WELL, FROM A LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO BREAK
THE LAWS AND MOST OF THE LAWS
THAT ARE BEING PUSHED IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW AND
NATIONALLY WHEN OBAMA WAS
PRESIDENT IS A COLLECTIVE
PUNISHMENT FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
ALREADY BREAK THE LAWS THAT
EXIST.
THEY DON'T REALLY BRING DOWN
GUN CRIME IN ANY WAY.
>> Tucker: SO THE
IMPLICATION OF A LOT OF THE
ARGUMENTS YOU HEAR IS AMERICA
HAS MASS SHOOTINGS BECAUSE
THERE ARE MORE GUNS.
DO WE HAVE MORE GUNS PER
CAPITA THAN WE ONCE HAD?
>> IT'S HARD TO QUANTIFY PER
CAPITA.
BUT IN THE '90s THERE WAS A
DIP IN CRIME.
FOR THE NEXT 25 YEARS THERE
WAS A BIG DIP IN CRIME AND GUN
OWNERSHIP SPIKED AT THE SAME
TIME.
SO THERE ARE MANY FACTORS IN
PLAY WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THAT.
BUT CERTAINLY YOU CAN'T BLAME
MORE PEOPLE HAVE GUN AND THERE
SHOULD BE MORE CRIME IF THE
THEORY HELD.
>> Tucker: SO IT'S NOT TRUE
THAT THE MORE GUNS THE
COMMUNITY HOLDS THERE IS MORE
VIOLENT CRIME?
>> WHETHER IT'S CHICAGO OR
WASHINGTON, D.C., COMPARED TO
A TOWN IN TEXAS WHERE EVERYONE
HAS A GUN.
IT'S CLEAR THAT IS NOT THE
CASE.
>> Tucker: SO I THINK YOUR
BOOK IS PRO SECOND AMENDMENT.
WHAT WOULD THE CASE BE THAT
YOU WOULD MAKE TO SOMEONE WHO
DOES NOT OWN A GUN BUT IS ON
THE FENCE, ON THAT QUESTION?
>> WELL, THE BOOK IS ABOUT THE
CULTURE OF GUNS, WHICH IS MORE
THAN JUST IDEOLOGICAL
QUESTION.
IT'S EMBEDDED IN THE CULTURE
OF AMERICA IN THE WAY WE DO
COMMERCE.
IN THE WAY WE TAME THE WEST.
MANY OTHER WAYS THAT IS PART
OF THE D.N.A. OF THE NATION.
SO THAT IS THE FIRST THING.
THAT IS WHY MANY AMERICANS
FEEL ABOUT GUNS THE WAY THEY
DO WHICH IS UNIQUE COMPARED TO
ANY OTHER NATION.
BUT TO CHANGE SOMEONE'S MIND,
I GUESS, ABOUT GUNS THEMSELVES
AND THE OWNERSHIP OF GUNS YOU
HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO THEM HOW
GUNS HELP THEM PROTECT THEIR
PROPERTY AND FAMILY.
AND THEY'RE RIGHT.
THAT, EVEN IF THE LAWS THEY
WANTED WERE PASSED THERE WOULD
STILL BE GUN VIOLENCE.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT THERE WOULD
BE ANY LESS GUN VIOLENCE THAT
WE HAVE TODAY.
BUT WE KNOW YOU WOULD BE LESS
ABLE TO PROTECT YOURSELF FROM
THE STATE OR FROM OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO HURT
YOU.
>> Tucker: YOU SAID HISTORY
AND THE PREMISE OF THE BOOK IS
HISTORY OF THE GUN IS EMBEDDED
IN THIS THE HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT IS NOT ACKNOWLEDGED AND
IT'S CHIDED AS A BAD THING.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> NO.
BUT THERE IS A REVISIONIST
EFFORT TO MAKE IT SEEM AS IF
GUNS WEREN'T AS IMPORTANT IN
HISTORY AS THEY WERE.
IT TIES IN THE POLITICS OF
TODAY.
THERE HAVE BEEN BOOKS, THERE
ARE BOOKS EVERYBODY NOW COMING
OUT WHERE HISTORIANS MAKE THE
CASE THAT GUNS WEREN'T
IMPORTANT IN AMERICAN LIGHT AN
COLLECTIVE RIGHT, NEVER
THOUGHT OF AS INDIVIDUAL
RIGHT.
HOPEFULLY IN MY BOOK I DISPEL
THAT NOTION AND DEBUNK IT.
>> Tucker: THIS IS AT THE
CENTER OF A LOT OF OUR